alors bien sûr il ya de plus en plus de
témoignages dont marie qui a 25 ans qui
est avec nous ce soir elle a été victime
d'abus sexuels de la part de son
entraîneur de 2009 à 2011 elle avait 14
ans elle souhaiterait rester anonyme
puisqu'elle travaille dans la fonction
publique elle est policière maintenant
son histoire elle va nous la raconter
parce qu'elle faisait elle du motocross
marie marie bonsoir marie consensuelles
alors marie donc vous faisiez du
motocross vous avez commencé à 7 ans et
vous aussi vous avez été victime d'un
d'un entraîneur c'est ça oui c'est ça en
fait j'ai commencé le motocross quand
j'étais petit mon cas sept ans avec mon
papa qui a balancé dans sa donc au début
c'était mon papa mon entraîneur donc
tout se passait bien et puis au bout
d'un moment quand mon niveau commencé à
augmenter il s'est tout de suite posé la
question d'avoir un entraîneur est
d'aller dans un centre de pilotage et
donc vous allez 14 ans vous avez un
nouvel entraîneur qui vous à proposer
des massages vous dit ouais en fait au
début tout se passait très bien et puis
petit à petit je commence à fréquenter
de plus en plus ce centre de pilotage et
son comportement a changé la fin 2009
oui me proposer des massages en me
disant tu sais les stages c'est très
éprouvant pour tes muscles pour éviter
que tuer des douleurs il faut que je te
masse et donc ça a commencé par les
moules et les épaules et sa très vite
continuer sur la poitrine et les fesses
les cuisses jusqu'à mars 2011 dans vos
16 ans oui et à la fin c'était tous les
jours plusieurs fois par jour ouais
c'est ça c'est à dire que je pense
qu'ils se sentaient un aussi un puissant
et qu'il agissait en toute impunité dont
qui se permettait de faire de plus en
plus et aujourd'hui je reste persuadé
que si j'étais resté la page
il m'aurait violée alors vous l'avez
fait confiance vous dites vous n'auriez
pas dire aux autres voilà ce qui se
passait ni à vos parents gelé dire mes
parents en début d'année 2011
d'accord et
bon la réaction n'a pas été seul
escompté puisque forcément il enfin il
faisait confiance aussi à cet entraîneur
là ils ont ramené votre parole en doute
ouais c'est ça c'est ça
alors vous êtes sorti du silence
officiellement en octobre 2014
en acceptant de témoigner auprès d'une
autre victime de cet entraîneur que lui
qui claquait la laisse est victime il
l'avait violée avant vous et là vous
êtes dit là je vais je vais témoigner
oui en fait cette cette jeune fille elle
me contactent début 2011 pour me dire
écoute moi il m'a fait ça il m'a violée
et sculpte white en fait elle est à la
recherche d'autres victimes pour pour
que sa parole et plus d'impact et et du
coup je lui dis ah ben oui m'a fait ça
il est en fait quand j'ai vu la réaction
des parents j'ai pas voulu m'engager
dans des poursuites j'étais tout seul
j'avais 16 ans je pouvais rien faire
d'accord alors la fédération a été
averti par l'autre victime en janvier
des agissements de cet entraîneur ils
n'ont pris aucune mesure préventive
sachez le et en plus de ça ils avaient
tout seul le statut de fonctionnaire et
comme le prévoit l'article 40 du code de
procédure pénale tout fonctionnaire doit
prévenir sans délai le procureur de la
république de tous les actes délictuels
ou criminels dont ils ont connaissance
voilà chose qui nous a absolument pas
fait encore à la fédération de qui a eu
un manquement encore à la fédération
pour vous vous dites que votre
entraîneur était protégé par la
fédération un ouais enfin c'est mon
ressenti puisque c'est vrai que le
motocross - ya très peu d'écoles de
pilotage enfants c'est un milieu où tout
le monde se connaît il faut savoir que
ce centre de pilotage là il est un site
d'excellence sportive et c'est la seule
école en france qui à ce statut là et
vous dites que le président était ami
avec lui et dans le monde du motocross
est une figure dont il ne fallait pas
salir en roumois entaché la réputation
c'est ce qu'on entend à chaque fois
parce qu'il ya des grands voilà des
grandes figures comme ça dans chaque
fédération dans chaque sport et à chaque
fois la fédération ne veut pas entacher
la personne alors où en est la procédure
sachez que l'entraîneur de mari a été
condamné fin 2008 à huit ans de prison
ferme par la cour d'assises pour viol
sur une élève mineure mélissa et
agressions sexuelles sur une autre élève
marie marie attaquer la fédération le 21
novembre 2019 pour avoir couvert ses
agissements et n'avoir pris aucune
mesure pour les faire cesser
marie réclame que la faute de la
fédération française de motocyclisme
soit reconnue
merci marie pour votre témoignage merci
beaucoup paris qui a souhaité garder
l'anonymat
les commissaires maintenant vendre il
est et bernard bour qui y est voilà vous
avez fait une enquête donc vous savez ce
qu'il va se passer
bernard dit nous la vérité est ce que tu
entends parler beaucoup de choses ou est
ce qu'on te dit en ce moment voilà ça va
être ça va être gros ce qui va se passer
on va en entendre d'autres choses dans
d'autres histoires je suis sûr qu'on va
en apprendre de plus en plus oui c'est
une certitude
la parole s'est libérée et tout le monde
tout le monde va parler c'est évident
que deux dans l'année qui arrive on va
prendre de plus en plus de choses
malheureusement m'étais malheureusement
oui malheureusement mais heureusement la
parole se libère
5 parce que si si ces gamins ne parle
pas on est encore une fois c'est
difficile pour un gamin de parler à son
papa et sa maman de voir si ils en
parlent directement il a un numéro vert
à la fédération et qui parlent toujours
à la même personne c'est plus simple
pour lui eh bien ça passe pas par le
club donc il peut pas dire j'ai posé des
désagréments aux clubs non pas du tout
j'ai averti la fédération personne ne le
saura et nous irons voir c'était cet
indicateur est inquiété sur l'éducateur
londres il nous ya des disciplines sur
lesquels on a enquêté où on a parlé
pendant de longs mois avec des champions
ou des championnes extrêmement connu un
conte qui ont été reconnus aux jeux
olympiques etc qui pour l'instant n'ont
pas souhaité parler de manière
officielle donc on peut aussi s'attendre
à ce que après sarah abitbol il ya aussi
ce genre de deux grands champions de
grande championne qui décide de parler
il faut l'espérer aussi surtout je pense
pour toutes les victimes anonymes qui
dépendent de ça un peu aussi pour
d'accord on prend la parole raymond et
ça parce que l'idée des bénévoles c'est
bien parce que ça va faire fuir aussi
celui qui a un casier ne viendra pas
parce qu'il aura son casier mois ces
espèces d'ordures qui s'amusent à jouer
avec des gamins de 9 en 15 ans là ce
qu'on vient de voir moi je suis content
de ce qu'on vient de voir pascal alex
est battu mary et écoutez bien huit ans
de prison
moi c'est ça que je retiens je suis
content huit ans de prison ferme parce
que d'abord les premières victimes c'est
à elle de parler parce qu'on ne peut
rien faire sans elle il ya l'histoire de
sarah abitbol qui est qui qui est
horrible mais elle parle après l' après
la présomption elle parle après 30 ans
tant mieux elle parle tant mieux elle
ouvre une voie après la prescription
tant mieux mais elle parle parce qu'elle
fait un livre les gens qui font pas de
livre comment ils font moi j'encourage
tous les gens parler parler comme l'a
dit bernard faut parler et ensuite je
veux que la justice derrière elle elle
les armes parce que si c'est pour aller
porter plainte réa paix après rappel à
la loi
ça démoralise tout le monde et ça
décourage tout le monde là il ya les
huit ans ferme c'est ça que je veux
qu'ils aient comme caisse de résonance
huit ans ferme il valait ans qui valent
anthony vadot rien y'a plein de gens qui
nous dit aussi et surtout parce que
c'est la question qu'on pose pourquoi on
n'a pas réagi plus tôt dans le sport
français parce que voilà on le voit il
ya plein de choses qui éclate et
personne n'en avait parlé avant il ya
plein de gens qui disent ils ce n'est un
petit peu tous donc voilà donc bien
c'est leur actif on a le gouverneur mais
je sais pas qui vous tenez les uns les
autres dans une fédération oui peut-être
me laver ni feng la route verte action
il saute pas ce que c'est ce sont les
moteurs d'une fédération va les toucher
etc
mais nous fédération fédération personne
ne se tient c'est pas vrai et je le dis
je le redis et en trois ans nous avons
traité 17 cas voilà sauf que comme tout
est un gars m'a pas chaque fois demandé
me bernard ripert tout fait pour dire
écoutez il ya une faille a eu ça on le
fait et encore une fois le plus
important c'est de faire les choses
d'accord oui c'est pas tellement je
pense que les gens ce thème c'est que la
société n'était pas prête à entendre on
était bien pas attendre sur deux choses
et encore il ya vingt ans il y avait
claude françois la démission qui disait
moi je préfère sortir une fille de 14
ans 15 ans elles sont plus fraîches
elles ont pas encore perdu et ça passe
crème tout le monde rigole personne ne
dit rien aujourd'hui dire et ça ça
serait tout de suite il est rentable
qu'on n'était pas prêts maintenant
heureusement le moment est venu
maintenant de dire les choses de
condamner alors on va voir ce qu'on
pense les téléspectateurs est il
possible de réagir plutôt oui bien sûr à
90%
non à 10%